[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis einen schönen guten abend
wünsche ich eben in den nächsten knapp
20 minuten erfahren sie hier die
wichtigsten nachrichten des tages dabei
schauen wir auch auf den sport
als erstes aber ein blick auf die
zapfsäulen
hoffen auf den tank rabatt gelten soll
er eigentlich ab morgen doch die sache
ist kompliziert und es könnte noch etwas
dauern bis die spritpreise spürbar
sinken
496 milliarden euro so viel geld will
die regierung im laufenden jahr ausgeben
und sich dabei ein weiteres mal massiv
verschulden und verantwortlich findet
die opposition
und harmonischer wechsel in hessen wenn
es der präsident volker bouffier geht
sein nachfolger boris rhein kommt und
erhält bei einer wahl auf stimmen aus
der opposition
beim tanken wird einem beim blick auf
den preis ja zurzeit ganz anders zwei
euro 20 2 euro 25 pro liter ab morgen
soll es billiger werden da die steuern
auf kraftstoffe sinken so die theorie
aber in der praxis sieht es nicht danach
aus dass die mineralölkonzerne diesen
tank rabatt gleich weitergeben werden
dabei war von der bundesregierung der
als entlastung für die autofahrerinnen
und fahrer gedacht
schauen wir uns mal an wie sich die
preise mai entwickelt haben für diese
hier schwarz und super e10 hier grün
dargestellt also wie sie sehen können
diese wurde erst billiger super teurer
und dann kurz vor dem tank rabatt gehen
die preise für beide kraftstoffe steil
nach oben sven regn mit den einzelheiten
diese freie tankstelle in hamburg
verkauft sprit oftmals zwei bis fünf
cent günstiger als die markenanbieter
auch jetzt kurz vor senkung der
mineralölsteuer kommen die kunden tanken
wenig und hoffen auf günstigere preise
ab morgen ich habe tatsächlich getankt
brecht tanken muss ich habe aber jetzt
endlich voll getankt weil es ja jetzt
dieses psychologische ist okay es wird
jetzt günstiger das können wir ja aus
der vergangenheit dass da
immer auch ordentlich abgezockt wird
tatsächlich ist nicht klar ob und wenn
ja um wie viel cent die kraftstoffpreise
überhaupt sinken die mineralölsteuer
wird nämlich ab tanklager berechnet
heißt also dass die tankstellen auch
erst ab 0 uhr heute nacht günstiger
einkaufen können und demnach noch ein
paar tage den teuren sprit bloß werden
müssen da würde natürlich der
tankstellenpächter jetzt auch verlust
machen wenn er das eher günstiger
ausgeben würde es macht also sinn einen
blick auf die zahlreichen preis apps zu
werfen denn nur so lässt sich vor dem
tanken erkennen wo es die
mineralölkonzerne mit dem spritpreis
rabatt nicht so genau nehmen wenn wir
erleben dass er schon seit wochen dass
einfach der verdacht im raum steht dass
die benzinpreise in deutschland
künstlich hochgehalten werden und
deswegen steht natürlich auch der
verdacht im raum dass nach der
einführung des tank rabatten spritpreise
nicht sofort untergehen sondern dass da
auch weiterhin kasse gemacht wird die
mineralölkonzerne kontern mit der hohen
nachfrage und gestiegenen
produktionskosten das bundeskartellamt
schaut sich jetzt auch die
preisentwicklung an den raffinerien an
vor allem in bezug auf den ölpreis wir
wollen uns das berühmte syndrom angucken
das mitunter der rohölpreis zwar fällt
aber die tankstellenpreise dem nicht
gleich schnell folgen wer also sparen
möchte tank besser nicht morgen weniger
nachfrage heißt nämlich sinkende preise
und die komplette steuerreduzierung wird
sich ohnehin erst nach und nach an den
zapfsäulen bemerkbar machen aber
dann wird es nun wirklich billiger dazu
begrüße ich unsere rechtsexperten sarah
zacke guten tag sarah sarah was kann
denn das kartellamt da wirklich
ausrichten leider sehr wahrscheinlich
nicht viel denn das große problem ist
dass die steuersenkung nicht an die
verbraucher weitergereicht werden kann
das heißt ob die preissenkung wirklich
an den tankstellen bei den autofahrern
auch ankommt liegt einzig in der hand
der tankstelle betreiber verpflichten
kann sie niemand und kontrollieren kann
das kartellamt auch nur bedingt das
patent ist keine überwachungsbehörde für
preiserhöhungen sondern hat nur zwei
möglichkeiten einzugreifen entweder er
stellt fest dass eine marktbeherrschende
stellung ausgenutzt wird sagen wir wir
uns wieder ist hier eher
unwahrscheinlich oder aber sie stellen
fest dass es illegale preisabsprachen
gibt und da sagen sie ganz klar illegale
preisabsprachen habe mineralölkonzerne
gar nicht nötig denn sie funktionieren
im grunde wie ein gut eingespieltes
altes ehepaar sie verstehen sich auch
ohne viele worte das heißt das licht
werden kann hier niemand kontrolliert
werden ja praktisch wird es aber
folgenlos bleiben sehr wahrscheinlich
welche anderen möglichkeiten gibt es
noch die preise unterzukriegen es gibt
verschiedene möglichkeiten die auch von
einigen unserer europäischen nachbarn
praktiziert werden eine möglichkeit ist
es zum beispiel benzin und dieselpreise
zu deckeln das aber wirklich ein krasser
eingriff in den markt ist auch
schwieriger als es so klingt nicht ganz
so simpel und echt folgenreich sehr viel
wahrscheinlicher und da ist bremen heute
auch vorgeprescht ist es eine
sondersteuer zu erheben also den gewinn
abzuschätzen und da will bremen auch in
entsprechenden antrag in den bundesrat
einbringen das heißt da ist wirklich
musik drin und da könnte auch politisch
noch einmal druck ausgeübt werden also
ist auch noch ein bisschen bewegung drin
danke für diese einschätzung seiner
tagaus unser recht redaktion
wer profitiert wie viel vom tank rabatt
darüber diskutiert auch zdf heute live
gleich unter anderem mit einem vertreter
der mineralölkonzerne um 19.25 in der
zdf- heute- app und auf unseren social
media kanälen
bisher importiert auch deutschland einen
teil seines öls aus russland aber damit
soll nun eu-weit möglichst bald schluss
sein nach der einigung auf dem
sondergipfel auf ein teilweises
ölembargo beim treffen wurde lange darum
gestritten ungarns ministerpräsident
orban habe buchloes gepokert so
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe ich über
den wichtigsten punkt im sechsten
sanktionspaket tom hallo
ein küsschen links küsschen rechts
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen und ratspräsident schale michelle
zeigen sich zufrieden nach dem
gefundenen kompromiss auch bundeskanzler
olaf scholz sieht im sanktionspaket ein
zeichen der geschlossenheit der eu und
dem öl embargo das klare ziel dass
russland seine aktivitäten mit
konsequenzen bezahlen wird die erheblich
sind für die wirtschaftliche
entwicklungsmöglichkeit und den
wohlstand russlands das öl-embargo sieht
so aus am ende des jahres darf kein
russisches öl mehr auf dem seeweg in die
eu transportiert werden weiterhin
geöffnet bleibt aber die druschba
pipeline ungarn die slowakei und
tschechien die stark auf die lieferungen
angewiesen sind können weiterhin das
russische öl beziehen wie lange genau
sie das dürfen und ob die weitere
zugeständnisse an ungarns premier viktor
orban gemacht hat dazu gibt es bislang
keine details aber feierte den beschluss
zuvor in einem video als sieg er steht
familien können heute nacht gut schlafen
die absurdesten ideen konnten wir
abwehren bis ende des jahres sollen fast
90 prozent der bisherigen russischen
öllieferungen in die eu beendet sein für
die eu ist der kompromiss durchaus ein
erfolg er zeigt aber auch wieder einmal
wie schnell die einigkeit bröckelt wenn
es um die nationalen interessen
einzelner länder geht und damit ist
nicht nur umgang gemeint denn bei den
nächsten verhandlungen kommen noch
knackpunkte die auch anderen wehtun
könnten einige länder möchten ein
embargo auf russisches gas auf die
tagesordnung setzen doch ein land das
dieses thema offenbar nicht beim
nächsten sanktionspaket diskutieren will
ist deutschland
bei ihrem treffen beschlossen die eu
staats und regierungschef in und chefs
auch weitere hilfen für die ukraine bis
zu neun milliarden euro soll das land
bekommen um zum beispiel krankenhäuser
am laufen halten zu können
unterdessen rücken in der ukraine die
angreifer weiter vor sind bereits in der
strategisch wichtigen stadt sehr froh
denn jetzt über das kriegsgeschehen line
aus die gefürchteten kämpferisch putin
treuen tschetschenen führers kadyrov
marschieren als erste ein auf dem
eigenen telegramm kanal posten sie diese
bilder inklusive kommentar
alles ist unter kontrolle
wir bewegen uns durch ein wohnviertel
und laufen auf den hauptstraßen richtung
industriegebiet
wir sind immer noch im straßenkampf sagt
dagegen der ukrainische gewann
foto netz finden jetzt kämpfe start aber
nicht in den außenbezirken die stadt ist
nicht vollständig eingenommen weder von
der kdf truppe noch von der russischen
armee
tag 97 dieses krieges serie donetsk
offenbar kurz vor dem fall lucie jones
die zwillingsstadt und das nahe bach mut
unter dauerbeschuss viele menschen sind
auf der flucht richtung pokorski
von hier fahren die flüchtlings züge die
meisten kommen aus den kampfgebieten um
severo donetzk familien auf der
verzweifelten suche nach sicherheit
die letzten tage waren die hölle
besonders mit kleinen kindern man
verlässt den schutzraum um essen zu
kochen und alles erzittert ich hätte
schon früher gehen soll
der zug soll sie ein stückchen weiter
nach westen bringen die großstadt nigro
unklar wie es von dort aus weiter geht
ungewiss auch die wiederkehr hauptsache
erst einmal weg aus dem don bass weg von
russischen angriffen
der ukraine helfen im krieg gegen
russland das kostet den westen viel geld
und hat auch folgen für den
bundeshaushalt
zumal der staat ja auch noch die
auswirkungen der korona pandemie
finanziell bewältigen muss in dieser
woche debattiert der bundestag über den
ersten haushalt der ampel koalition und
so sehen die zahlen aus der bund plant
in diesem jahr ausgaben in höhe von 496
milliarden euro zum teil finanziert
durch neue schulden die betragen 139
milliarden euro immerhin deutlich
weniger als im vergangenen jahr nicht
eingerechnet sind hier allerdings die
100 milliarden die zusätzliche die
bundeswehr fließen sollen über die
debatte patrizier wieder meyer
es ist der erste haushaltsentwurf des
finanzministers und entgegen aller
wahlversprechen der fdp ein entwurf mit
der bisher zweithöchste neuverschuldung
kein wunder dass es heftige kritik der
opposition gab wir haben in diesem land
vollbeschäftigung und wir haben auch
rekordbeschäftigung mit 45 millionen
beschäftigten die in die sozialkassen
einzahlen trotzdem sind wir nicht in der
lage daraus die rente zu finanzieren wir
können die krankenkasse nicht
finanzieren wir können die pflege auch
nicht finanzieren die afg ist der
auffassung dass auch dieser haushalt
wieder erneut verfassungswidrig ist man
darf keine notkredite aufnahmen um
rücklagen zu bilden was sie aber auch 22
erneut getan haben das ist und bleibt
ein missbrauch des ausnahme artikels für
die linke sind vor allem die 100
milliarden euro viele bundeswehr viel zu
viel für die rüstung was soll man mit
diesen 100 milliarden alles sinnvolles
tun man könnte zum beispiel alle schulen
in der bundesrepublik sanieren und sie
wissen auch dass es viele dringend nötig
haben corona der ukraine krieg und die
steigenden energie- und
lebensmittelpreise würden die rund 140
milliarden neuer schulden rechtfertigen
hält finanzminister lindner dagegen
mehreinnahmen würden den bürgern
zurückgegeben wir antworten auf die
sicherheitspolitische zeitenwende mit
der stärkung der streitkräfte wir
antworten auf die ökonomische
zeitenwende der inflation durch die
rückkehr zu soliden haushalten und das
ende immer neuer schulden wir betreiben
aber nicht nur aktive krisenbewältigung
sondern wir sorgen auch für die zukunft
vor wir konnten seit beginn der
ampelkoalition
das volumen des energie und klimafonds
für die nächsten jahre auf fast 200
milliarden euro verdoppeln im nächsten
jahr soll dann die schuldenbremse wieder
eingehalten werden verspricht christian
lindner angesichts der großen aufgaben
fraglich ob das gelingen wird
trotz krieg und stottern der
weltwirtschaft am arbeitsmarkt läuft es
weiter ziemlich gut zumindest was die
arbeitslosenquote angeht sie liegt
inzwischen wieder auf dem vorstand nach
den offiziellen zahlen waren im mai 2
millionen 260.000 menschen ohne job das
sind 50.000 weniger als im april
die quote sinkt leicht auf 4,9 prozent
im vergleich zum mai vor einem jahr sind
428.000 menschen weniger arbeitslos
nach hessen dort wurde deutschlands
dienstältester ministerpräsident in den
ruhestand verabschiedet volker bouffier
der inzwischen 70-jährige war fast zwölf
jahre regierungschef in wiesbaden
gemeinsam mit dem grünen tarek al wazir
wurde bei 42 sich 13 zum architekten
einer schwarz grünen koalition
am frühen nachmittag die staffelübergabe
boris rhein ist der neue
ministerpräsident linken klinge
berichtet
auf den vorschlag boris rhein entfielen
ja stimmen 74 die wahl lief glatt fünf
stimmen mehr als nötig und als die
schwarz-grüne regierungskoalition
zusammen bringt für boris rhein applaus
im landtag und offensichtliche
erleichterungen beim scheidenden und
beim neuen ministerpräsidenten ich habe
vor mit dieser schwarz grünen koalition
noch sehr viele punkte zu setzen um zu
zeigen dass wir noch sehr viel schwung
haben als schwarz grünen dass wir noch
sehr viel dynamik haben und dass wir
noch sehr viele ideen haben für dieses
bundesland
die karriere von boris rhein zuletzt
landtagspräsident lief nicht immer
reibungslos als innenminister in hessen
war er auch umstritten
2012 verlor er die oberbürgermeisterwahl
in seiner heimatstadt frankfurt am main
volker bouffier nimmt heute abschied
nach 50 jahren politik durchaus wehmütig
seine stimme hatte auch auf bundesebene
gewicht erstarkte angela merkel stets
den rücken vom konservativen hardliner
als innenminister unter roland koch
wandelte er sich zum ausgleichenden
landesvater und schmid 2013 schließlich
das erste schwarz grüne bündnis in einem
flächenland das bis heute stabil ist
vermitteln wird sein großes anliegen
gerade in zeiten der krise und des
krieges und dann wird es immer
schwieriger wird eine gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten
habe ich mich bemüht nicht das trennende
sondern das gemeinsame
hervorzuheben boris rhein muss sich nun
schnell als ministerpräsident beweisen
denn in knapp eineinhalb jahren stehen
in hessen die landtagswahlen an
auch in nordrhein westfalen stehen die
zeichen auf schwarz grün dort haben cdu
und grüne mit ihren
koalitionsverhandlungen begonnen die
landeschefin der grünen mona neubaur
sagte zu beginn der gespräche es gebe
mit der cdu jetzt ans eingemachte
gemeinsame pläne wieder ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung bis 20.30 und ein
größeres budget für schulen und polizei
müssen jetzt ausgearbeitet werden
heute ist weltnichtrauchertag und dazu
gibt es diese zahl aus deutschland ein
drittel der über 14-jährigen greift
regelmäßig zur zigarette
der rauch anteil ist weiter gestiegen
sucht forschende vermuten einen
zusammenhang mit der korona pandemie
laut statistischem bundesamt starben im
jahr 2020 rund 75.500 menschen in
deutschland an den folgen des rauchens
er zählt zu den bedeutendsten autoren
der gegenwartsliteratur
nun ist der schriftsteller friedrich
christian delius im alter von 79 jahren
gestorben
in seinen romanen und erzählungen
verarbeitete fc delius die geschichte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wie in der
sonntag an dem ich weltmeister wurde der
georg büchner preisträger waren jungen
jahren teil der legendären
schriftstellervereinigung gruppe 47
und dann freuen wir uns noch mit einer
kollegin katrin eigendorf erhält einen
der renommierten grimme preise für ihre
reportagen aus afghanistan sie habe
empathisch und mutig die situation von
frauen und mädchen in afghanistan der
taliban dokumentiert so die jury dabei
habe sie viel sensibilität für die
frauen und ihre situation gezeigt katrin
eigendorfs reportagen hätten einen
konzentrierten und vielschichtigen
überblick über die entwicklung
afghanistans im vergangenen jahr gegeben
und jetzt kommen wir zum sport zu den
beiden deutschen fußball-nationalteams
norbert aber als erstes schauen wir noch
die männer ja die leute ihren ersten
trainingstag in herzogenaurach dort
bereitet sich die mannschaft auf die 4
nations league länderspiele vor schon am
samstag geht es richtig zur sache beim
spiel gegen europameister italien
zusammen mit rund 1000 menschen aus der
region rennen die nationalspieler für
den guten zweck einlauf der auf die
verschmutzung der weltmeere aufmerksam
machen soll beim frühsport fehlt der
erkrankte royce doch flick stehen noch
25 spieler zur verfügung die in der
nations league bestehen wollen wenn ich
mir jetzt an gruppe dass wir gegen
italien england ungarn spielen das sind
absolute prestige duell von daher fällt
es mir glaube ich jetzt und auch der
mannschaft nicht schwer sich für diese
spieler zu motivieren und das große
vorfreude zu haben schon das spiel in
italien wird zu einer echten
standortbestimmung wie ein blick in
seinem kader vorne sieht
ja nun zum deutschen frauenfußball team
da wurde heute der kader für die em in
england vorgestellt alexandra popp ist
die kapitänin je acht spielerinnen
kommen vom double-gewinner vfl wolfsburg
und vom vizemeister bayern münchen
schnell wie die afag ist neuer box
europameister im superschwergewicht der
23-jährige holte gestern abend im
armenischen eriwan das erste deutsche em
gold im boxen seit fünf jahren
die deutsche fahne und nationalhymne
sind im boxsport durchaus etwas
besonderes gehisst und gespielt wurden
sie für navy cis
der bergheimer mit kamerunischen wurzeln
zeigte sich gegen den spanier ayad war
von beginn an als der boxer der den
kampf in den meisten phasen dirigierte
auch
physisch war zweifach seinen gegner klar
überlegen und zwang ihn in runde zwei
mehrfach auf die knie zu beginn der
dritten runde kam aus der spanischen
ecke das handtuch als zeichen der
aufgabe tja fahrt wird sich nun auf die
olympischen spiele 2000 24 in paris
vorbereiten und danach zu den profis
wechseln bei der mann ist eine echte
medaillen-hoffnungen für die olympischen
sommerspiele 2024 in paris gearbeitet
das wetter zeigt sich morgen im norden
von seiner wechselhaften seite sonst ist
es meist freundlich alles weitere dazu
von christa orden bettina schausten hat
um 21.45 das heute-journal für sie das
ganze heute team und ich wünschen ihnen
einen schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend bei uns meteorologen besteht
der frühling aus märz april und mai und
damit geht heute der trip sonnigste
frühling seit aufzeichnungsbeginn zu
ende und auch der neunte zu trockene
frühling in folge immerhin gibt es heute
nacht im norden ja einige schauer und
gewitter in denen etwas regen zusammen
kommt auch im süden bayerns regnet ist
das ganze lässt bis morgen früh aber
rasch nach es wird wieder sehr kühl bis
morgen früh bei fünf bis elf grad
bodenfrost wird jetzt aber immer weniger
wahrscheinlich der meteorologische
sommer der startet dann morgen ganz
unterschiedlich am ehesten spürt es sich
noch fühlt es sich noch im süden danach
an bei 19 bis 25 grad im norden bleibt
es deutlich kühler bei 15 bis 18 grad
hier liegt das eben an den vielen wolken
die unterwegs sind auch kurze schauer
und gewitter immer mal wieder bringen
können zwischen dem niederrhein und der
neiße und südlich davon bleibt es aber
immer öfter trocken und viel
sonnenschein zwischen rheinland pfalz
und dem saarland und nordbayern erst
mittags kommt dann aus den alpen heraus
auch wieder einige kurze schauer und
gewitter südlich der donau anja und zum
ende der woche da wird es aus süden
immer wärmer damit steigt aber auch die
unwettergefahr wieder an